hello
i'm gav
oh
[Music]
oh
i'm dan
in this video we will be attempting a
challenge that i think was tweeted to me
in about 2016 so
timely that's right yeah we're going to
be attempting to put these swim cut
on my head
just by diving into it just without
touching it just in case you didn't have
enough time to get ready to swim before
you dived in yeah it's a useful
technique you know in like triathlons
and stuff when they're always in a rush
to do stuff yeah if they had just like a
slipping around a hat wrangler to like
throw it on just as they dive in that'd
be perfect primo yeah all right
get your lab coat off i just
wore the lab coat for about a minute
then
still got my sort of hairy coat on
though so it's fine i think it looks
good b cheers b
um
so what's your sort of technique for
going getting this on your head oh right
well i mean i'm about to jump into a
nice cold pool in the middle of january
but
we're in texas so it's kind of like the
peak of english summer yeah so i'm not
going to worry about that i'm just going
to worry about you know that diagram
when it says do not die well no diving
and it looks like cracking his head on
the floor yeah i'm just going to try and
avoid that
so other than avoiding that
i'm going to just try anything i can to
get it on my head just
dive straight towards it and i think and
then i've got to film it success i think
the hardest part the bit we're going to
struggle with the most is my ability to
throw potentially
she's gonna be jumping in the pool loads
should we just get this first try yeah
okay turn it inside out three two one
[Laughter]
that wasn't bad you know no it wasn't
eyes on the ball is that a frame at the
moment there's not even any indication
of your safety you're just good for it
you're not even looking where you're
landing no
look at my legs and hands there's
comfort like a salmon bit into it
straight up salmond it
at this point you've realized it's not
gone ideally and now you've got
you've got to deal with where you're
going
three two one
[Applause]
going for it head first
you committed you knew it was bad and
you still commit look i have to go for
it
oh god
are you typically one who goes for
headers usually oh no i have absolutely
no prowess in the air whatsoever
i play as a striker in football but if
there's one thing i can't do it's head
the ball any time i've ever tried in the
past it's always like [ __ ] him in the
face
or just not gone anywhere near i wanted
to do so i just kind of gave up and i've
never got good at it so this doesn't
really bode well for what we're trying
to do here i like that you've got all
the dexterity in the world as well
you're two feet on the ground the moment
you're in the air it's all out the
window
yeah
okay you're gonna switch to this black
one
potentially a bit more grip so it
doesn't slide off your head three
two
three two one
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
concentration face is back
i knew it was a good log immediately i
was like yeah this is promising do you
think at this point you know it's going
to be good i think i'm thinking at this
point it's going to be good as closer
and closer as i get to i'm like yeah
this is this is going to work have
anyone seen this thumbnail i don't know
what like what's going on
[Music]
[Laughter]
majestic it like went around your face
it like
framed your face briefly majestic
at least it's washing all the dirt off
three
right in the damn face i mean 10 out of
10 for commitment i'd say 2 out of 10
for technique yeah if you wore a swim
cap on your face
[Music]
should we go back to the black one here
we go three two one
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh straight on
you just emerged
it's a beard with a hat yeah potentially
get like a much closer sort of 90 degree
one
[Laughter]
the noises that you make when coming up
from underwater are so different to your
normal noises
oh you're getting it i think you've got
it every time with this black one
perfect two three
[Applause]
keep doing that
look at me
breathe in
i'm swim ready
i'm ready for the championship
breathe out be it
[Laughter]
oh it's like when i had the condom on my
head
that's really good
you're classy that
yeah
oh look at that
it's spot on that's perfect
and you're just ready
just ready for the water
if we could find a way to blast your
shorts on the way that would be
i could have had a blow-dried haircut
before
just like jump straight in and be
perfectly fine
so this will be much closer and a more
intricate look at what's actually going
on and it'll also be a slight bit of
redemption for a shot that we couldn't
get
many years ago
yeah nothing to do with the swim cap my
face is actually shrunk
i'm just going to drop it straight down
on the top of your face and hopefully
this new grippy style of swim hat won't
bounce right off yeah my neck won't
break
[Laughter]
okay you ready
yeah
it's so high does it need to be that
high i think it does oh god all right
three two one
[Laughter]
i breathed out and it just flew off
again
i holded my i hold it
i holded my breath because i thought
that i was going to be like struggling
to get it off and i wouldn't be able to
breathe i just breathed out and it
came straight off again
oh i just backed it off that works so
well
you just
fired off your face
oh you can tell by your face it's coming
in
it's imminent
oh you're coming to me it you're doing
like micro adjustments yeah
[Music]
that's a complete wrap
it just deposited i just left my ear on
show
you oh you got my double chin you didn't
get the double chin in me
i only hooked one chin
oh no i had too many chins
face completely
right do it again
it's great i think the front chin is
perfect
[Laughter]
i'm booking it to the camera now i think
it's inflating
they're trying to breathe out
the silhouette is a little bit behind
the scenes there
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh it's brilliant
oh a lovely day out of the pool
yeah middle of january perfect the
depths of winner good looking footage
too yeah i was happy with it i'm just
glad to be back it was a lot of fun
messing around filming some stuff glad
to have you back yeah yeah make sure you
leave a big fat welcome back for dan in
the comments i hope you enjoyed that
video um very much appreciate it if
you've watched all the videos on the
channel in the last couple of years
we'll now be referring to that period as
the dark times oh i'll try not to have
that again yeah well i will see you in
the next video see you next time make
sure you subscribe if you like slo-mo
and you like dan
well i mean i'm quite divisive i feel
like people will be like oh actually
[Music]
slipping around a hat wrangler to like
throw it on just as they dive in that'd
be perfect primo yeah all right
get your lab coat off